no objection so ordered the sergeant and
arms will make the proclamation here
they hear ye hear ye all persons are
commanded to keep silent on pain of
imprisonment while the Senate of the
United States is sitting for the trial
of the articles of impeachment exhibited
by the House of Representatives against
Donald John Trump President of the
United States the majority leader is
recognized any colleagues no motion no
motions were filed this morning so we'll
proceed to the house managers
presentation will go for approximately
two hours and take a short recess when
there is an appropriate breakdown
between presenters pursuant to the
provisions of Senate resolution 483 the
managers for the House of
Representatives have 24 hours to make
the presentation of their case the
center will now hear you
[Music]
mr. chief justice
senators counsel for the president and
my fellow house managers I want to begin
by thanking you Chief Justice for a very
long day for the way you have presided
over these proceedings and I want to
thank the Senators also we went well
into the morning as you know until I
believe around 2:00 in the morning and
you paid attention to every word an
argument you heard from both sides in
this impeachment trial and I know we are
both deeply grateful for that it was an
exhausting day for us
certainly but we have adrenalin going
through our veins and for those that are
required to sit and listen it is a much
more difficult task and of course we
know our positions you have the added
difficulty of having to weigh the facts
in the law so I want to begin today by
thanking you for the conduct of the
proceedings yesterday and for inviting
your patience as we go forward we have
some very long days yet to come so let
us begin
when a man unprincipled in private life
desperate and his fortune bold in his
temper possessed of considerable talents
having the advantage of military habits
despotic in his ordinary demeanor known
to have scoffed in private at the
principles of Liberty when such a man is
seen to mount the hobbyhorse of
popularity to join in the cry of danger
to Liberty to take every opportunity of
embarrassing the general government and
bringing it under suspicion to flatter
and fall in with all the nonsense of the
zealots of the day it may justly be
suspected that his object is to throw
things into confusion that he might ride
the storm and direct the whirlwind those
words were written by Alexander Hamilton
in a letter to President George
Washington at the height of the
panic of 1792 a financial credit crisis
that shook our young nation Hamilton was
responding to sentiments related to
Washington as he traveled the country
that America in the face of that crisis
might descend from a Republican form of
government plunging instead into that of
monarchy the framers of the Constitution
worried then as we worry today that a
leader might come to power not to carry
out the will of the people that he was
elected to represent but to pursue his
interests they feared that a president
would subvert our democracy by abusing
the awesome power of his office for his
own personal or political gain and so
they devised a remedy as powerful as the
evil it was meant to combat impeachment
as centuries have passed our founders
have achieved an almost mythical
character we are aware of their flaws
certainly some very painful and
pronounced indeed and yet when it came
to the drafting of a new system of
government never seen before and with no
guarantee it would succeed we cannot
help but be in all of their genius their
prescience even vindicated time and time
again still and maybe because of their
brilliance and the brilliance of their
words we find year after year it more
difficult to imagine them as human
beings this is no less true of Alexander
Hamilton notwithstanding his recent
return to celebrity but they were human
beings they understood human frailties
even as they exhibited them they could
appreciate just as we can how power can
corrupt and even as we struggle to
understand how the framers might have
responded to presidential misconduct of
the kind and character that we are here
to try we should not imagine for one
moment that they lacked basic common
sense or refused to apply it ourselves
they knew what it was like to live under
a despot and they risked their lives to
be free of it they knew they were
creating enormous ly powerful executive
and they knew they needed to constrain
it they did not intend for the power of
impeachment to be used frequently or
over mere matters of policy but they put
it in the Constitution for a reason for
a man who would subvert the interests of
the nation to pursue his own interests
for a man who would seek to perpetuate
himself in office by inviting foreign
interference and cheating an election
for a man who would be disdainful of
power ignoring or defeating the other
branches of government and their
co-equal powers for a man who believed
that the Constitution gave him the right
to do anything he wanted and practiced
in the art of deception for a man who
believed that he was above the law and
beholden to no one for a man in short
who would be a king we are here today in
this hallowed chamber undertaking the
solemn action for only the third time in
history because Donald J Trump the 45th
president of the United States has acted
precisely as Hamilton and his
contemporaries feared president Trump
solicited foreign interference in our
democratic elections abusing the power
of his office to seek help from abroad
to improve his re-election prospects at
home and when he was caught he used the
powers of that office to obstruct the
investigation into his own misconduct to
implement this corrupt scheme president
Trump pressured the president of Ukraine
to publicly announce investigations into
two discredited allegations that would
benefit president Trump's 2020
presidential campaign when the Ukrainian
President did not immediately assent
president Trump withheld two official
acts to induce the Ukrainian leader to
comply ahead of state meeting in the
Oval Office and military funding both
were great consequence to Ukraine and to
our national interest in security but
one looms largest president Trump
withheld hundreds of millions of dollars
in military aid to a strategic partner
war with Russia to secure foreign help
with his re-election in other words to
cheat in this way the president used
officials state powers available only to
him and unavailable to any political
opponent to advantage himself in a
democratic election his scheme was
undertaken for a simple but corrupt
reason to help him win reelection in
2020 but the effect of his scheme was to
undermine our free and fair elections
and to put our national security at risk
it was not even necessary that Ukraine
undertake the political investigations
the president was seeking they merely
had to announce them this is significant
for president Trump had no interest in
fighting corruption as he would claim
after he was caught rather his interest
wasn't furthering corruption by the
announcement of investigations that were
completely without merit
the first sham investigation that
President Trump desired was into former
Vice President Joe Biden who had sought
the removal of a corrupt Ukrainian
prosecutor the previous during the
previous US administration the vice
president acted in accordance with US
official policy at the time and was
supported unanimously by our European
allies and key global financial
institutions such as the International
Monetary Fund that shared the concern
over corruption despite this fact in the
course of this scheme President Trump
and his agents pressed the Ukrainian
presidents who announced an
investigation into the false claim that
Vice President Biden wanted the corrupt
prosecutor removed from power in order
to stop an investigation into BER yzma
holdings on board Biden's son hunter sat
this allegation is simply untrue and it
has been widely debunked by Ukrainian
and American experts alike that reality
mattered not to President Trump to him
the value in promoting a negative tale
about former Vice
President Biden - or false was its
usefulness to his reelection campaign it
was a smear tactic against a political
opponent the president Trump apparently
feared remarkably but predictably Russia
too has sought this to support this
effort to smear mr. Biden reportedly
hacking into the Ukrainian energy
company at the center of the president's
disinformation campaign only last week
Russia almost certainly was looking for
information related to the former vice
president's son so that the Kremlin
could also weaponize it against mr.
Biden just like it did against Hillary
Clinton in 2016 when Russia hacked and
released emails from her presidential
campaign and president Trump has made it
abundantly clear that he would like
nothing more than to make use of such
dirt against mr. Biden just as he made
use of Secretary Clinton sacked and
released emails in his previous
presidential campaign which brings us to
the other sham investigation that
President Trump demanded that the
Ukrainian leader announce this
investigation was related to a debunked
conspiracy theory alleging that Ukraine
not Russia interfered in the 2016
presidential election this narrative
propagated by the Russian intelligence
services contends that Ukraine sought to
help Hillary Clinton and harm then
candidate Trump and that a computer
server providing this fiction is hidden
somewhere in Ukraine that is the
so-called CrowdStrike
conspiracy theory this tale is also
patently false and remarkably it is
precisely the inverse of what the US
intelligence community's unanimous
assessment was that Russia interfered in
the 2016 election in sweeping and
systemic fashion in order to hurt
Hillary Clinton and help Donald Trump
nevertheless the president evidently
believed that a public announcement
lending credence to these allegations by
the Ukrainian president could assist his
reelection by putting to rest any doubts
Americans may have had over the
legitimacy of his first election even as
he invited for an interference in the
next to the degree that most Americans
have followed the president's efforts to
involve another foreign power in our
election they may be most familiar with
his entreaty to the Ukrainian president
on the now infamous July 25th called to
do us a favor though and investigate
Biden and the 2016 conspiracy theory but
that call was not the beginning of the
story of the president's corrupt scheme
nor was it the end rather was merely
part although a significant part of a
months-long effort by President Trump
and his allies and associates who plied
significant and increasing pressure on
Ukraine to announce these two
politically motivated investigations key
figures in the Trump administration were
aware or directly involved or
participated in the scheme as we saw
yesterday one witness a million dollar
donor to the president's inaugural and
for everyone was in the loop after twice
inviting Ukraine's new president to the
White House without providing a specific
date for the proposed visit president
Trump conditioned this coveted head of
state meeting on the announcement of
these sham investigations for Ukraine's
new and untested leader an official
meeting with the President of the United
States in the Oval Office was critical
it would help bestow on him important
domestic and international legitimacy as
he sought to implement an ambitious
anti-corruption platform actual and
apparent support from the President of
the United States would also strengthen
his position as he sought to negotiate a
peace agreement with russia's President
Vladimir Putin seeking an end to
Russia's illegal annexation and
continued military occupation of parts
of Ukraine but most pernicious president
Trump conditioned hundreds of millions
of dollars in congressionally
appropriated
taxpayer-funded military assistance for
the same purpose to apply more pressure
on Ukraine's leader to announce the
investigations this military aid which
has long enjoyed bipartisan support was
designed to help Ukraine defend itself
from the Kremlin's aggression more than
15,000 Ukrainians have died fighting
Russian forces and their proxies 15,000
and the military aid was for such
essentials as sniper rifles
rocket-propelled grenade launchers radar
night-vision goggles and other vital
support for the war effort most
critically the military aid that we
provide Ukraine helps to protect an
advanced American national security
interests in the region and beyond
America has an abiding interest in
stemming Russian expansionism and
resisting any nations efforts to remake
the map of Europe by dint of military
force even as we have tens of thousands
of troops stationed there moreover as
one witness put it during our
impeachment inquiry the United States
aid Ukraine and her people so that we
can fight Russia over there and we don't
have to fight Russia here now when the
president's scheme was exposed and the
House of Representatives properly
performed its constitutional
responsibilities to investigate the
matter president Trump used the same
unrivaled authority at his disposal as
commander in chief
to cover up his wrongdoing in
unprecedent fashion the president
ordered the entire executive branch of
the United States of America to
categorically refuse and completely
obstruct the houses impeachment
investigation such a host sale
obstruction of encroachment
congressional impeachment has never
before occurred in our democracy and it
represents one of the most blatant
efforts that a cover-up in history if
not remedied by his conviction in the
Senate and removal from office president
Trump's abuse of his office and
obstruction of Congress will permanently
alter the balance of power among
branches of government inviting future
presidents to operate as if they are
also beyond the reach of accountability
congressional oversight and the law on
the basis of this egregious misconduct
the House of Representatives returned
two articles of impeachment against the
president first charging the
presidential power among of the
presidency to solicit foreign
interference in the upcoming
presidential election for his personal
political benefit and second the
president Trump obstructed an
impeachment inquiry into that abuse of
power in order to cover up his
misconduct the house did not take this
extraordinarily extraordinary step
lightly as we will discuss impeachment
exists for cases in which the conduct of
the president rises beyond mere policies
disputes to be decided otherwise
and without urgency at the ballot box
instead we are here today to consider a
much more grave matter and that is an
attempt to use the powers of the
presidency to cheat in an election for
precisely this reason the president's
misconduct cannot be decided at the
ballot box for we cannot be assured that
the vote will be fairly one in corruptly
using his office to gain a political
advantage in abusing the powers of that
office in such a way to jeopardize our
national security and the integrity of
our elections in obstructing the
investigation into his own wrongdoing
the president has shown that he believes
that he's above the law and scornful of
constraint as we saw yesterday on the
screen that under Article two he could
do anything he wants
moreover given the seriousness of the
conduct at issue and its persistence
this matter cannot and must not be
decided by the courts which apart from
the presence of the Chief Justice here
today are given no role in impeachments
in either the house
or the Senate being drawn into
litigation taking many months or years
to complete would provide the president
with an opportunity to continue his
misconduct he would remain secure in the
knowledge that he may tie up that
Congress in the courts indefinitely as
he has with Don began rendering the
impeachment power effectively
meaningless we also took this step with
the knowledge that this was not the
first time the president solicited
foreign interference in our elections in
2016 then candidate Trump implored
Russia to hack his opponents email
accounts something that the Russian
military agency did only hours later
only hours later when the president said
hey Russia if you're listening they were
listening only hours later they hacked
his opponents campaign and the president
has made it clear this was also not be
the last time asking China only recently
to join Ukraine in investigating his
political opponent over the coming days
we will present to you and to the
American people the extensive evidence
collected during the houses impeachment
inquiry into the president's abuse of
power overwhelming evidence
notwithstanding his unprecedented and
wholesale obstruction of the
investigation into that misconduct you
will hear and read testimony from
courageous public servants who upheld
their oath to the Constitution and their
legal obligations to comply with abuse
coracle order by President Trump not to
cooperate with the impeachment inquiry
these are courageous Americans who were
told by the President of the United
States not to cooperate not to appear
not to testify but who had the sense of
duty to do so
but more than that you will hear from
witnesses who have not yet testified
like John Bolton and Mick Mulvaney Mr
Blair and mr. Duffy and if you can
believe the president's words last month
you will also hear from secretary Pompeo
you will hear their testimony at the
same time as the American people that is
if you allow it if we have a fair trial
during our presentation you will see
documentary records those the president
was unable to suppress that exposed the
president's scheme in detail you will
learn further evidence that has been
revealed in the days since the House
voted to impeach President Trump even as
the president and his agents have
persisted in their efforts to cover up
their wrongdoing from Congress and the
public and you will see dozens of new
documents providing new and critical
evidence of the president's guilt that
remain at this time in the president's
hands and in the hands of the Department
of Defense and the Department of State
and the Office of Management budget even
the white US you will see them and so
will the American people if you allow it
if in the name of a fair trial you will
demand it
these are politically charged times
tempers can run high particularly where
this president is concerned but these
are not unique times deep divisions and
disagreements were hardly alien concepts
to the framers so they designed the
impeachment power in such a way as to
insulate it as best they could from the
crush of partisan politics the framers
placed the question of removal before
the United States Senate a body able to
Rea rise above the fray to soberly judge
the president's conduct or misconduct
for what it was nothing more and nothing
less in Federalist 65
Hamilton wrote where else than in the
Senate could have been found a tribunal
sufficiently dignified or sufficiently
independent what other body would be
likely to feel confidence enough in this
own situation to preserve an odd and
uninfluenced the necessary impartiality
between an individual accused and the
representatives of the people his
accuser it is up to you to be the
tribunal that Hamilton envisioned it is
up to you to show the American people
and yourselves that his confidence and
that of the other founders was rightly
placed the Constitution entrusted
responsible to the sponsibility of
acting is impartial jurors to hold a
fair and thorough trial and to weigh the
evidence before you no matter what your
party affiliation or your vote in the
previous election or the next our duty
is to the Constitution and to the rule
of law the founders was recognized there
will be times during the trial that you
may long to return to the business of
the Senate the American people look
forward to the same but not before you
decide what kind of democracy that you
believe we ought to be and what the
American people have a right to expect
in the conduct of their president the
house believes that an impartial juror
upon hearing the evidence that the
managers will lay out in the coming days
will find that the Constitution demands
the removal of Donald J Trump from his
office as president of the United States
but that will be for you to side with
the weight of history upon you and as
President Kennedy once said a good
conscience your only sure reward
in drafting our Constitution the framers
designed a new and untested form of
government it would be based on free and
fair elections to ensure that our
political leaders would be chosen
democratically and by citizens of our
country alone haven't broken free from a
king with unbridled Authority you often
place his own interests above that of
the people the framers established a
structure that would guarantee that the
chief executives power flowed only from
his obligation to the people rather than
from a sovereign whose power was
conferred on him by divine right in this
new architecture no branch of government
or individual would predominate over
another in this way the founders ensured
that their elected leaders and their
president would use the powers of office
only to undertake that which the people
desired and not for their personal
aggrandizement or enrichment what are
those who rebelled and fought a
revolution desire no different than what
we the generations that have followed
desire that no person including and
especially the president would be above
the law nothing could be more dangerous
to a democracy than a commander-in-chief
who believed that he could operate with
impunity free from accountability
nothing that is except a congress that
is willing to let it be so to ensure
that no such threat could take root and
subvert our fledgling democracy the
framers divided power among three
co-equal branches of government the
executive the legislative and the
judicial branches so that ambition may
be made to counter ambition they
provided for presidential elections
every four years and the framers
required that the president swear an
oath to faithfully execute the law and
to preserve protect and defend the
Constitution of the United States even
with these guardrails in place the
framers understood that individual could
come to power who defied that solemn
oath who pursued his own interests
rather than those of the country he led
for that reason the framers adopted a
tool used by the
Parliament to constrain its officials
the power of impeachment rather than a
mechanism to overturn an election
impeachment would be a remedy of last
resort and unlike in England the framers
applied this ultimate check to the
highest office in the land to the
President of the United States
impeachment and removal of a duly
elected president was not intended for
policy disputes or poor administration
of the state instead the framers had in
mind the most serious of offenses
hamilton explained that impeachment was
not designed to cover only statutory or
common law crimes but instead crimes
against the body politic Hamilton wrote
the subjects of its jurisdiction are
those offenses which proceeded from the
misconduct of public men or in other
words from the abuse or violation of
some public trust they are of a nature
which may with peculiar propriety be
denominated political as they relate
chiefly to injuries done immediately to
society itself in other words
impeachment would be confined to abuses
of people's trust and to the society
itself this is precisely the abuse that
has been undertaken by our current
president when he withheld money and
support for an ally at war to secure a
political benefit the punishment for
those crimes would fit the political
nature of the offense as James Wilson a
delegate at the Constitutional
Convention in a future Associate Justice
of the Supreme Court reasoned
impeachment Sarco find two political
characters two political crimes and
misdemeanors and two political
punishments that punishment the framers
determined would be neither prison nor
fines but instead limited to removal
from office and disqualification from
holding future office the framers chose
to undertake impeachment for treason
bribery or other high crimes in
misdemeanors to underscore the
requirements of an offense against
society in this phrase hi modifies both
the crimes and the misdemeanors in that
both relate to a high injustice a
transgression committed against the
people and to the public trust the
framers had two broad categories in mind
those actions that are facially
permissible under the president's
authority but are based on corrupt
motives such as seeking to obtain a
personal benefit through public office
and those at far exceed the president's
constitutional authority or violate the
legal limits on that authority in
article 1 we deal with the first evil
which the framers wish to guard against
that is cases in which a president
corruptly misused the power otherwise
bestowed on him to secure a personal
reward guarding against the present who
undertakes official acts with the
corrupt motive of helping himself is at
the heart of the impeachment power as
one scholar explained the president's
duty to faithfully execute the law
requires that he undertakes actions only
when motivated in the public interest
rather than in their private
self-interest efforts to withhold
official acts for personal gain
counterman the president's sacred oath
and therefore constitute impeach the
behavior as it was conceived of by the
framers in article 2 we also deal with a
second evil contemplated by the founders
who made it clear that the president
ought not operate beyond the limits
placed on him by legislative and
judicial branches impeachment was
warranted for a president who usurped
the power of the Constitution that was
not granted to him such as to defy
Congress the right to determine the
propriety the scope and the nature of an
impeachment inquiry to his own
misconduct a parade beyond the framers
fashioned a powerful chief executive but
not one beyond accountability of law
when a president wields power in ways
that are inappropriate and
seek to distinguish the rights of the
Congress he exceeds the power of his
constitutional authority and violates
the limits placed on his conduct
obstruction of a separate and co-equal
branch of government for the purposes of
covering up an abuse of power not only
implies a corrupt intent but also
demonstrates a remarkable antipathy
towards the balance of power
contemplated and enshrined in our
Constitution it is a betrayal of the
president's sacred oath of office and of
his duty to put the country before
himself on September 24th 2019 Speaker
of the House Nancy Pelosi announced that
the House of Representatives would move
forward with an official impeachment
inquiry into President Donald J Trump
the announcement followed public
reporting in the United States and
Ukraine that the president and his
agents sought ukraine's help in his
reelection effort and revelations that
the White House was blocking from
Congress an intelligence community
whistleblower complaint possibly related
to this grave offense the next day on
September 25th under extraordinary
pressure the White House released
publicly the record of the July 25th
call between President Trump and
ukrainian President Vladimir is olanski
the call record revealed that President
Trump explicitly requested that the new
leader undertake investigations
beneficial to president Trump's
reelection campaign upon release of the
record of the call President Trump
claimed that the call was perfect far
from perfect the call record revealed a
president who used his high office to
personally and directly press the leader
of a foreign country to do his political
dirty work asking for a favor President
Trump insisted that President Solinsky
investigate a formidable potential
political opponent former Vice President
Joe Biden
as well as the baseless conspiracy
theory that Ukraine not Russia
interfered in the 2016 election to in
sit to assist then candidate Trump's
opponent witnesses who listened to the
call as a transpire testified that they
immediately recognized these requests
did not represent official US policy and
instead were politically charged appeals
not appropriate for a president to make
key witnesses emphasized it was not
necessary that Ukraine actually
undertake the investigations only that
the Ukrainian president announced them
president Trump's objective was not to
encourage a foreign government to
investigate legitimate allegations of
misconduct or wrongdoing abroad made
clear as well by the fact that the
investigations he wanted announced have
been discredited entirely rather the
president simply wanted to reap a
political benefit by tarnishing a
political rival and in attempting to
erase from history his previous election
misconduct to compel the Ukrainian
president to do his political dirty work
president Trump withheld from President
Solinsky two official acts of great
importance to that covenant to which the
president you Solinsky had already been
invited and 391 million in military
assistance Ukraine needed to fight the
Russians for strategic partner of the
United States in a hot war with Russian
backed forces inside its own borders the
symbolic support conferred on it by an
oval office visit with the president of
the United States and the life-saving
support of our military aid was
essential as the houses presentation
will make clear and directly soliciting
foreign interference and withholding
those official acts in exchange for the
announcement of political investigations
beneficial to his reelection
the president put his own interests
above the national interest
president Trump undermined the integrity
of our free and fair elections by
pressing a foreign power to influence
our most sacred right as citizens our
right to freely choose our leaders and
he threatened our national security by
withholding critical aid from a partner
on the front lines of war with Russia an
aggressor that has threatened peace and
stability on an entire continent in so
doing the president sacrificed not only
the security of our European allies but
also our nation's core national security
interests
president Trump undertook this pressure
campaign through handpick agents inside
and outside of government who
circumvented traditional policy channels
president Trump intentionally bypassed
many US government career officials with
responsibilities over Ukraine and
advanced his scheme primarily through
the effort of his personal attorney Rudy
Giuliani president Trump carried out
this scheme with the knowledge of senior
administration officials including the
president's acting chief of staff Mick
Mulvaney Secretary of State Mike Pompeo
vice president Mike Pence national
security council legal adviser John
Eisenberg and White House Counsel Pat
Cipollone II when the president became
aware that the scheme would be uncovered
he undertook an unprecedented effort to
obstruct the House of Representatives
impeachment inquiry and to hide it from
the public and from Congress including
all evidence related to his misconduct
that cover-up continues today as
administration has not provided a single
document
pursuant to lawful subpoenas by the
house administration also continues to
prevent witnesses from cooperating
further obstructing the house efforts
the president is no doubt proud of but
which threaten the integrity of this
institution now this Congress as a
co-equal branch of power our ability not
only to do oversight but to hold a
president who is unindicted
accountable
but despite these efforts to obstruct
our inquiry the House of Representatives
uncovered overwhelming evidence related
to the president's misconduct through
interviews with 17 witnesses who
appeared before the intelligence
Oversight and Reform and Foreign Affairs
committees many of these witnesses
bravely defied White House orders not to
comply with duly authorized
congressional subpoenas and we're it not
for them we're not for ambassador Murray
Ivanovich who was this breach we may
never have known at the present scheme I
want you to imagine for a minute what
kind of courage that took for ambassador
Jovanovic the subject of that vicious
smear campaign to risk her reputation
and her career to stand up to the
President of the United States who's
instructing her through his agents you
will not cooperate you will not testify
you will tell them nothing
or bill Taylor West Point graduate
Vietnam veteran with a Bronze Star and
something he was even more proud of the
combat infantry infantryman's badge he
knows what courage is showed a different
kind of courage in Vietnam but he also
showed courage as did others and coming
forward in defying the president's order
that he obstruct to tell the American
people what he knew but for the courage
of people like this and Colonel
Lieutenant Colonel VIN Minh a Purple
Heart recipient but for their courage we
would have known nothing of the
president's misconduct nothing when the
president directs his ire towards these
people this is why because they showed
the courage to come forward now we held
in the intelligence committee seven open
hearings with 12 fact witnesses
separately the Judiciary Committee held
public hearings with constitutional law
experts and counsel from the
intelligence House Intelligence
Committee as it sought to determine
whether to draft and consider articles
of impeachment the house also collected
text messages related to the president's
scheme from a witness who provided
limited personal communications since
the conclusion of our inquiry new
evidence has continued to come to light
through court ordered releases of
administration documents and public
reporting underscoring that there is
significantly more evidence of the
president's guilt which he continues to
block from Congress including the Senate
nevertheless the documents and testimony
that we were able to collect paints an
overwhelming and damning picture of the
president's efforts to use the powers of
his office to corruptly solicit foreign
help in his re-election campaign
and withhold official acts and military
aid to compel that support over the
coming days you will hear remarkably
consistent evidence of president Trump's
corrupt scheme and cover-up when you
focus on the evidence uncovered during
the investigation you will appreciate
there is no serious dispute about the
facts underlying the president's conduct
and this is why you will hear the
president's lawyers make the astounding
claim that you can't impeach a president
for abusing the powers of his
affiliation you because they can't
seriously contest that that is exactly
exactly
what he did and so they must go find a
lawyer somewhere apparently they could
not go to their own attorney general who
was just reported in a memo he wrote as
part of the audition for attorney
general which opined that a president
can be impeached for abusing for public
trust couldn't go to Bill Bar for that
opinion couldn't go to even Jonathan
Turley their expert in the house where
that opinion no they had to go outside
of these experts outside of the
constitutional law to a criminal defense
lawyer and professor and why because
they can't contest the facts the
president was the key player in the
scheme everyone was in the loop he
directed the actions of his team he
personally asked the foreign government
to investigate his opponent these facts
are not in dispute ultimately the
question for you is whether the
president's undisputed actions require
the removal of the 45th President of the
United States from office because he
abused his office and the public trust
by using his power for personal gain by
seeking elicit foreign assistance in his
re-election and covering it up other
than voting on whether to send our men
and women to war this is
I think no greater responsibility before
you than the one before you now the oath
that you've taken to a partially weigh
the facts and evidence requires serious
and objective consideration decisions
that are about country not party about
the Constitution not politics about what
is right and what is wrong
after you consider the evidence and
weigh your oath to render a fair and
impartial verdict I suggest to you today
the only conclusion consistent with the
facts and law not just the law but the
Constitution is clear as described by a
constitutional law experts testimony
before the house if this conduct is not
impeachable then nothing is let me take
a moment to describe to you how we
intend to present the case over the
coming days today you will hear the
details of the president's corrupt
scheme in narrative form illustrating
the timeline of the effort through the
testimony of numerous witnesses who came
before the house as well as the
documents and materials we collected as
evidence during the investigation after
you hear the factual chronology we will
then discuss the constitutional
framework of impeachment as it was
envisioned by the founders before we
analyze how the facts of the president's
misconduct and coverup lead to the
conclusion that the president undertook
the sort of corrupt course of conduct
that impeachment was intended to remedy
let me start with a preview of the
president's scheme the details of which
you'll hear during the course of this
day president Trump's month-long scheme
months-long scheme to extract help in
his 2020 reelection campaign from the
new cranium president involved an effort
to solicit and then compel the new
leader to announce political
investigations the announcement would
reference reference to specific
investigations is
to undermine the unanimous consensus of
our intelligence agencies Congress and
Special Counsel Robert Muller that
Russia interfered in the 2016 election
to help then candidate Trump and another
to hurt the presidency a former Vice
President Joe Biden the Kremlin itself
has been responsible for first
propagating one of the two false
narratives that the president desired in
February 2017 less than a month after
the US intelligence community released
its assessment that Russia alone was
responsible for covert influence
campaign designed to help President
Trump win the 2016 election President
Putin said as we all know during the
presidential campaign in the United
States the Ukrainian government adopted
a unilateral position in favor of one of
the candidates in favor of one candidate
more than that certain oligarchs
certainly with the approval of political
leadership funded this candidate or
female candidate to be more precise
those were Putin's words February 2nd
2017 of course this is false and as part
of a Russian counter narrative that
President Trump and some of his allies
have adopted fiona hill senior director
for europe and russia at the National
Security Council described Russia's
effort to promote this baseless theory
based on questions and statements I've
heard some of you on this committee
appear to believe that Russia and its
security services did not conduct a
campaign against our country and that
perhaps somehow for some reason Ukraine
did this is a fictional narrative that
has been perpetrated and propagated by
the Russian security services themselves
the unfortunate truth is that Russia was
the foreign power that systematically
attacked our democratic institutions in
2016 this is the public conclusion of
our intelligence agencies confirmed in
bipartisan congressional reports
it is beyond dispute even if some of the
underlying details must remain
classified this of course was not the
first time that President Trump embraced
Russian activity and disinformation
on July 24 of last year Special Counsel
Robert Muller testified before Congress
that Russia interfered in the 2016
election in a quote sweeping and
systemic fashion to benefit Donald
Trump's political campaign Muller and
his team found that quote the Russian
government perceived that it would
benefit from a trump presidency and
worked to secure that outcome they also
found that the Trump campaign expected
it would benefit electorally from
information stolen and released through
Russian efforts and just as he solicited
help from Ukraine in 2019 in 2016 then
candidate Trump also solicited to help
from Russia in his election effort as
you will recall at a rally in Florida he
said the following Russia if you're
listening I hope you're able to find the
30,000 emails that are missing I think
you will probably be rewarded mightily
by our press let's see if that happens
following special counsel Muller's
testimony during which he warned against
future interference in our elections did
the president recognize the threat posed
to our democracy and renounce Russian
interference in our democracy did he
choose to stand with his own
intelligence agencies both houses of
Congress and the special counsels
investigation in affirming that Russia
interfered in our last election he did
not instead only one day after special
counsel Muller testified before Congress
empowered in the belief that he had
evaded accountability for making use of
foreign support in our last election
President Trump was on the phone with
the president of Ukraine pressing him to
intervene on presidents Trump's behalf
in the next election let's
a moment to let that sink in July 24th
Bob Muller concludes a lengthy
investigation he comes before the
Congress he testifies that Russia is
systemically intervened in our election
to help elect Donald Trump that the
campaign understood that and they
willfully made use of that help Jay 24th
that's what happens the very next day
the very next day he's on the phone
president Trump is on the phone with a
different foreign power this time
Ukraine trying to get Ukraine to
interfere in the next election the next
day that should tell us something that
should tell us something he did not feel
shamed by what the Special Counsel found
he did not feel deterred by what the
Special Counsel found he felt embolden
by escaping accountability for the very
very next day he's on the phone
soliciting foreign interference again
now
that July 25th phone call between
President Trump the president Solinsky
was a key part of president Trump's
direct and corrupt solicitation of
foreign help in the 2020 election the
requests likely sounded familiar to
President Solinsky who had been swept
into office and a landslide victory on a
campaign of rooting out just the type of
corruption he was being asked to
undertake on this call with our
president Solinsky campaigned as a
reformer as someone outside of politics
would come up and clean up corruption
who would end the political prosecutions
and the political investigations and
what is his most empower important and
powerful patron asking him to do to do
exactly what he campaigned against no
wonder he resisted this pressure
campaign now President Trump had been
provided talking points for discussion
by the National Security Council staff
beforehand including recommendations to
encourage President Solinsky to continue
to promote anti-corruption reforms in
Ukraine so the national security staff
understood what was in the u.s. national
security interests and that was rooting
out corruption and they encouraged the
president to talk about it but as you
see from the record of the call and I
joined the president saying read the
call that topic was never addressed the
word corruption never escapes his lips
instead president Trump openly pressed
President Solinsky to pursue the two
investigations that would benefit him
personally in response to president
solinsky's gratitude for the significant
military support the United States has
provided to Ukraine President Trump said
I would like you to do a face a favor
though because our country has been
through a lot and Ukraine knows a lot
about it I would like you to find out
what happened with this whole situation
with Ukraine they say CrowdStrike
I guess you have one of your wealthy
people the server
they say Ukraine has it that's that
crazy conspiracy theory I talked about
earlier that there's this server
somewhere in Ukraine that shows that in
fact it was Ukraine that hacked the DNC
not the Russians that's a Russian
propaganda conspiracy theory and here it
is being promulgated by the President of
the United States and more than
promulgated he's pressuring an ally to
further this Russian propaganda because
he was referring to this extensively
discredited conspiracy theory that
Ukraine was the one who really hacked
the DNC the Democratic National
Committee servers in 2016 and that
referenced a crowd strike well that's an
American cybersecurity firm and the
theory this kooky conspiracy theory is
that CrowdStrike moved the DNC servers
to Ukraine to prevent US law enforcement
from getting them if Ukraine announced
an investigation into this fabrication
president Trump would remove what he
perceived to be a cloud over his
legitimacy legitimacy of his last
election Russia's assistance with his
campaign and suggests that it was the
Democratic Party that was the real
beneficiary of help on the call
President Trump told Solinsky whatever
you can do it's very important that you
do it if that's possible
president szalinski agreed that he would
do the investigation saying yes it is
very important for me
and everything that you just mentioned
earlier President Trump then turned to
his second request asking president
Solinsky to look into the Shama
allegation in to former Vice President
Biden President Trump said to President
Solinsky the other thing there's a lot
of talk about Biden's son that Biden
stopped the prosecution and a lot of
people want to find out about that so
whatever you can do with the Attorney
General would be great
Biden went around bragging that he
stopped the prosecution so if you
look into it it it sounds horrible to me
there is no question that President
Trump intended and pressing the Ukraine
leader to look into his political rival
even after the impeachment inquiry began
he confirmed his desire on the South
Lawn of the White House declaring not
only that Ukraine should investigate
Biden but the China should do the same
let's let's see what he said well I
would think that if they were honest
about it that sort of major
investigation into the Biden it's a very
simple answer they should investigate
devises because how does a company
that's newly formed and all these
companies if you look at and by the way
likewise China should start an
investigation into the Biden because
what happened to China is just about as
bad as what happened with with Ukraine
now the day after that July 25th phone
call
president Trump sought confirmation that
President Solinsky understood his
request to announce the politically
motive investigators and that he would
follow through after meeting with
Ukrainian officials president Solinsky
and his top aide the president's
hand-picked ambassador to the European
Union Gordon Sunland called President
Trump from an outdoor restaurant in Kiev
to report back this was the second
conversation between the two about
Ukraine in his many days David Holmes an
American diplomat dining with song land
overhanging with Ukraine including the
president's voice through the cell phone
I described part of that call last night
Holmes testified that President Trump
asked Sunland
so he's going to do the investigation
son replied that he's going to do it
adding that President Solinsky will do
anything you ask him to after the phone
call Holmes took the opportunity to ask
ambassador Solomon for his candid
impression of the president's views on
Ukraine according
two homes in particular I asked
ambassador Soglin if it was true that
the president did not give a expletive
about Ukraine bass her song and agreed
that the president did not give an
expletive about Ukraine I asked why not
neva sir songlist stated to the
president only cares about big stuff I
noted there was big stuff going on in
Ukraine like a war with Russia an
ambassador silent replied that he meant
big stuff that benefits the president
like the Biden investigation that mr.
Giuliani was pushing the conversation
then moved on to other topics those
three days in July the 24th the 25th and
the 26th reveal a lot about president
Trump's effort to solicit help from a
foreign country in assisting his own
re-election on the 24th special counsel
Muller testifies that Russia interfered
in our 2016 election election to assist
the Trump campaign she knew about the
interference welcomed it and utilized
that that's the 24 the 25th and Trump
believing he'd escaped accountability
for Russian meddling in the first
election and is welcoming of it asked
the Ukrainian president to help him
undermine the special counsels
conclusion and helped him smear a
political opponent former Vice President
Biden and then the third day in a row in
July President Trump
sought to ensure that Ukraine had
received his request and understood it
and would take the necessary steps to
announce the investigations that he
wanted three days in July in many ways
those threes days in July tells so much
of this story this course of conduct
alone should astound all of us who value
the sanctity of our elections and who
understand that the vast powers of the
presidency are reserved only for actions
which benefit the country as a whole
rather than the political fortunes of
any one individual
president Trump's effort to use an
official head of state phone call to
solicit the announcement of
investigations helpful to his reelection
is not only conduct unbecoming a
precedent but his conduct of one who
believes that the powers of his high
office are political tools to be wielded
against his opponents including by
asking a foreign government to
investigate a United States citizen and
for a corrupt purpose that alone is
grounds for removal from office of the
45th president but these three days in
July were neither the beginning nor the
end of this scheme president Trump
acting through agents inside and outside
of the US government including his
personal attorney Rudy Giuliani sought
to compel Ukraine to announce the
investigations by withholding the head
of state meeting in the Oval Office and
applied hosting an oval office of
meeting for a foreign leader is an
official act available only to one
person the President of the United
States and it is an official act that
President Trump had already offered to
prison president szalinski during their
first phone call on April 21st and in a
subsequent leader letter to the
Ukrainian leader multiple witnesses
testified about the importance of a
White House meeting for Ukraine for
example deputy assistant secretary
George Kent explained that a White House
meeting was very important for
Ukrainians to demonstrate the strength
of their relationship with Ukraine's
strongest supporter dr. Fiona Hill of
the National Security Council explained
a White House meeting would supply the
new Ukrainian government with quote the
legitimacy it needed especially these
are the the Russians and that the
Ukrainians viewed a White House meeting
as a recognition of their legitimacy as
a sovereign state this White House
meeting would also prove to be important
for three handpick agents
whom president Trump placed in charge of
us Ukraine issues ambassador sunland
ambassador Volcker and Energy Secretary
Rick Perry the so called three amigos
they hope to convince President Trump to
hold an oval office meeting with
szalinski during a meeting of the three
amigos on May 23rd President Trump told
them that Ukraine had tried to take him
down in 2016 he then directed them
talked to Rudy Giuliani about Ukraine it
was immediately clear that Giuliani
who was pursuing the discredited
investigations in Ukraine on the
president's behalf was the key to
unlocking an oval office meeting for
President Solinsky Giuliani by then had
said publicly that he was actively
pursuing investigations president trump
corruptly desired and planning a trip to
Ukraine
Giuliani admitted quote were not
meddling in an election were meddling in
an investigation on May 10 however
Giuliani canceled the trip to Ukraine to
dig up dirt on former Vice President
Biden and the 2016 conspiracy theory
Justice President Solinsky won elections
for the presidency in Parliament faced
with a choice between working with
Giuliani to pursue an oval office
meeting understanding it meant taking
part in a corrupt effort to secure the
political investigations or abandoning
efforts to support our Ukrainian Ally
the president's agents fell into line
they would pursue the White House
meeting and explain to Ukraine that
announcements of the investigations was
the price of admission as ambassador
Salman made clear I know that members of
this committee frequently framed these
complicated issues in the form of a
simple question was there a quid pro quo
as I testified previously with regard to
the requested White House call in the
White House meeting the answer is yes
this quid pro quo was negotiated between
the president's agents Rudy Giuliani and
Ukrainian officials throughout the
summer of 2019 in numerous telephone
calls texts tests including during a
meeting hosted by then National Security
Advisor John Bolton on July 10th near
the end of that July 10th meeting after
Ukrainians again raised the issue of a
White House visit ambassador Sandlin
blurted out that there would be
agreement for a White House meeting once
the investigations began at that point
Bolton immediately stiffened and
abruptly ended the meeting during a
subsequent discussion that day Sunland
was even more explicit lieutenant
colonel Alex of Inman a director for
Europe and Ukraine on the National
Security Council testified that Sandlin
began to discuss the deliverable
required to get the White House meeting
which song and specifically mentioned
was investigation of the Biden's this is
again in that meeting in the White House
with Ukrainian a Ukrainian delegation
and an American delegation Sandlin
explained in that meeting he had an
agreement with acting chief of staff
Mick Mulvaney whereby President Solinsky
would be granted the oval office meeting
if he went forward with the
investigations after the meeting
ven-ven's supervisor dr. hill reported
back to bolton who told her to tell John
Eisenberg the National Security Council
legal adviser that he was not part of
whatever drug deal Sunland and Mulvaney
are cooking up on this she reported her
concerns as did bin Minh it remains
unclear what action if any Bolton or
Eisenberg took once they were made aware
of Mulvaney and sunland's drug deal both
refused to testify in our inquiry
however dr. hill testified that she
understood that mr. Eisenberg informed
mr. Sibal oniy of her concerns about the
drug deal if this body is serious about
a fair trial one that is fair to the
president
and to the American people we again urge
you to allow the house to call both
Eisenberg and Bolton as well as other
key witnesses with first-hand knowledge
who refused to testify before the house
on the orders of the President
additional testimony and documents are
particularly important because according
to Sunland everyone was in the loop when
it came to the president's self-serving
effort in part relying on email excerpts
Sandlin explained that the president's
senior aides and cabinet officials knew
that the White House meeting was
predicated on Ukraine's announcement of
the investigations beneficial to the
president's political campaign Hill
characterized the quid pro quo
succinctly but it struck me one
yesterday when you put up on the screen
ambassador Sunderland's emails and who
was on these emails and he said these
that people who need to know that he was
absolutely right because he was being
involved in a domestic political arrant
and we were being involved in national
security foreign policy and those two
things had just diverged in effect
president Solinsky was being drawn into
this domestic political errand he grew
weary of becoming involved in another
country's election and domestic affairs
bill Taylor the acting US ambassador to
Ukraine at the time described a
conversation he had with a senior aide
to the Ukrainian leader he said also he
who were stationed with alexander daniel
duke president zelinsky's national
security adviser who emphasized that
presidents Lenski did not want to be
used as an instrument in a u.s.
reelection campaign remember that
conversation when you hear counsel say
that the Ukrainians felt no pressure to
be involved in a u.s. reelection
campaign but that concern did not deter
President Trump in his conversation
Sandlin short before shortly before the
25th of July call the president made
clear that he not only wanted Ukraine to
do the investigations or announced them
but also a White House meeting would
only be scheduled if president Solinsky
confirmed these investigations as
Volcker communicated to President
solinsky's top aide by text less than 30
minutes before the phone call between
Trump and szalinski and again we're
talking about July 25th in a text 30
minutes before the Trump Solinsky phone
call here's what is said with Volcker
texting under a year Macha top aide to
president Solinsky good lunch
thanks heard from White House assuming
president Z convinces Trump he will
investigate quote get to the bottom of
what happened unquote in 2016 we will
nail down date for a visit to Washington
good luck see you tomorrow
Kurt well that those words couldn't be
much clearer assuming president Z
convinces Trump he will investigate get
to the bottom of what happened in 2016
we'll nail down the visit to Washington
that's a text 30 minutes before that
call counsel for the president like do
you think this is just about that call
you don't get to look outside the four
corners of that call they don't want you
look at the months that went into
preparing for that call or the months
the pressure that followed it but you
could just look at right now
what happened 30 minutes before that
call in this text message heard from
White House assuming president Z
convinces Trump II will investigate get
to the bottom what happened in 2016 if
you are wondering how it seemed that
President Solinsky was aware of what he
was going to be asked on that call this
is how you can tell he was prepped of
course he was prepped and in fact the
the missing reference in the call rec
tuber yzma
was a signal
Colonel amendment recognized that
clearly he had been prepped for that
call why else would the name of this
particular energy company come up in
that conversation well president
Solinsky clearly got the message toward
the end of the call with President Trump
president Solinsky said I also want to
thank you for your invitation to visit
the United States specifically
Washington DC on the other hand I also
want to ensure you wanted to ensure you
that we will be very serious about the
case and we will work on the
investigation thank you for the
invitation on the other hand I want to
assure you that we will be very serious
about the case and we will work on the
investigation to ensure this key clearly
understood the quid pro quo for the
White House meeting on July 25th
but his reticence to be used as a
political pawn kept President Trump from
moving forward with a promise to
schedule the meeting and so the
president and his agents pressed on in
August Giuliani met with a top Ukrainian
aide and made it clear that Ukraine must
issue a public statement announcing the
investigations in order to get the White
House meeting fearful of getting
involved in u.s. domestic politics and
having entered office with a promise to
clean up government and corruption
president Solinsky and his aides
preferred a generic statement about
investigations but Giuliani insisted no
the statement must include two specific
investigations that would benefit
president Trump let's look at a
comparison between the statement the
Ukrainians preferred and the one that
Giuliani required
on the left and I will read in case you
can't see the screens the draft the Year
mock draft the Ukrainian draft says we
intend to initiate and complete a
transparent and unbiased investigation
of all available facts and episodes
which in turn will prevent the
recurrence of this problem in the future
that's pretty generic but here's the
Giuliani Volcker song 'land response
this is what had to be included we
intend to initiate and complete a
transparent and unbiased investigation
of all available facts and episodes up
to that point it's exactly the same
until you get to including those
involving BER yzma and the 2016 US
elections and then it goes back to the
Ukrainian draft which in turn will
prevent the recurrence of this problem
in the future you can see in this such
graphic evidence ukrainians did not want
to do this they didn't even want to
mention this Giuliani had to insist no
no we're not gonna be satisfied with
some generic statement after all I think
we can see this isn't about corruption
no this isn't about announcing
investigations to damage Biden and to
promote this fiction about the last
election so here in these texts you see
that Giuliani Volcker and Saleh Nevada
these references to Burr yzma a thinly
veiled reference to former Vice
President Biden and the 2016 election
they wish to ensure the Ukrainians
mentioned the Sham investigations
president Trump required now the
Ukrainians recoiled at the new statement
recognising that releasing it would run
directly counter to the anti-corruption
platform that Solinsky campaigned on and
wouldn't embroil them in u.s. election
politics as a result Solinsky didn't get
his White House beating he still hasn't
gotten his White House meeting Senators
witness testimony text messages emails
and the call record itself confirm a
corrupt quid pro quo for the White House
meeting an official Act available only
to the president United States in
exchange for the announcement of
political investigations the president
whose allies have offered no explanation
for this effort
except the president can abuse his
office all he likes and there's nothing
you can do about it the show can't
impeach him that is because they cannot
seriously dispute the president Trump
corruptly used an official White House
visit for a foreign leader to compel the
Ukrainian president into helping him
cheat in the next election the White
House meeting of course was not the only
official act that President Trump
conditioned on the announcement of
investigations into Biden and the
conspiracy theory meant to exonerate
President Trump from Russians
interference on his behalf in the last
election in a far more draconian step as
we have discussed the president withheld
391 million dollars of military aid
several weeks before this phone call
with President Solinsky
but after Giuliani was already pressing
Ukrainian officials to conduct the
investigations his clients sought
present Trump ordered the hold on
Ukraine's military aid significantly
this was after Congress had already been
notified that most of it was prepared to
be spent Ukraine had met all of the
critical conditions for anti-corruption
and defense reforms in order to receive
the funds we conditioned the funds they
met the conditions the funds were ready
to go at the time and even today
witnesses uniformly testified that the
order to hold the funding came without
explanation to the foreign policy and
national security officials responsible
for Ukraine the only message from the
Office of Management and Budget was that
the hold was implemented at the
direction of the president since
Russia's illegal incursion into Ukraine
in 2014 the US has maintained a
bipartisan policy of delivering hundreds
of millions of dollars of military aid
to Ukraine each year which several
senators here have personally invested
significant time
an effort to ensure and it was President
Trump himself who originally authorized
additional financial support for
military assistance to Ukraine in 2017
and 2018 without reservation making his
abrupt decision to withhold assistance
in 2019 without explanation all the more
surprising to those responsible for
Ukraine policy that confusion however
would soon disappear the president used
the whole of military aid as leverage to
pressure Ukraine to announce these
investigations that he hoped would help
his reelection campaign the only
difference between the prior years when
the president approved the aid without
question and the inexplicable aid on
hold in 2019 was the emergence of Joe
Biden as a potentially formidable
obstacle to the president's re-election
these funds that the president withheld
these funds they don't just benefit
Ukraine they benefit the security of the
United States by ensuring that Ukraine
is equipped to defend its own borders
against Russian aggression as ambassador
Taylor noted in his deposition the
United States provides Ukraine with
radar and weapons and sniper rifles
communication that save lives it makes
Ukrainians more effective it might even
shorten the lure aliens can defend
themselves and the Russians in the end
will say okay we're going to stop that's
in our interest this is just about
Ukraine or its national security it's
about our national security this isn't
charity
it's about our defense as much as
Ukraine's ambassador Taylor also said
that the American aid was a concrete
demonstration of the United States
commitment to resist aggression and to
defend freedom
that's what this country is supposed to
be about right resisting aggression
defending freedom not exporting corrupt
ideas that's what we're supposed to be
outright it was against this backdrop
that American officials responsible for
Ukraine policy sat in astonishment
according to ambassador Taylor when they
learned about the hold officials
immediately expressed concerns about the
legality of President Trump's hold on
assistance Ukraine their concerns were
well warranted as the Government
Accountability Office which was just
last night poo-pooed is by the
President's Council was just some
institution of Congress right they're
gonna be just inherently biased right
well they're a nonpartisan organization
that both parties have come to rely upon
but I'm not surprised they don't like
the inclusion of the GAO because the
Defense Department warned them that this
was going to be the conclusion and that
conclusion was the hold on aid was not
only wrong it was not only immoral it
was also illegal it violated the law a
law that we passed so that presidents
could not refuse to spend funny that we
allocated for the defense of others and
for ourselves the impoundment Control
Act prevents the President and other
government officials from unilaterally
making funding decisions when Congress
has made its intent clear in fact the
exactly Act exists precisely because of
previous presidential abuses of
Congress's power the purse during the
Nixon era the nonpartisan GAO ruled that
the hold on military aid was not only
illegal but that holding underscores the
president's efforts to go to any lengths
to ensure his own personal benefit
rather than take care that the laws be
faithfully executed as he swore he would
do when he took his oath of office
now because of recent Freedom of
Information Act responses and media
reports we now know additional details
about how senior officials express
serious reservations about the legality
of the hold at the time so this is this
is not like some new surprise this is
not like something that just came out of
the blue Oh independent watchdog agency
found this was illegal no they knew this
was illegal at the time these concerns
were raised at the time certain
individuals who may have further
information about the whole that refused
to testify at the president's Direction
including his chief of staff Mick
Mulvaney his deputy Robert Blair OMB
official Michael Duffy all of them all
of them defied congressional subpoenas
but were included in important email
communications that have been made
public only recently as you know these
in-house Defense Department OB were
subpoenaed by the house and none was
produced none at the president's
direction and through mr. Sibal oneis
intervention although the investigation
developed an overwhelming body of
evidence that clearly proves that the
president implemented this hold to
pressure Ukraine to announce
investigations the full story behind the
hold the full and complete story is
within your power to request as you
consider the evidence we present to you
ask ourselves whether the documents and
witnesses that have been denied by the
president's complete and unprecedented
obstruction could shed more light on
this critical topic you may agree with
the house managers that the evidence of
the president's withholding a military
aide to coerce Ukraine is already
supported by overwhelming evidence and
no further insight is necessary to
convict the president but if the
president's lawyers attempt to contest
these or other factual matters you are
left with no choice but to demand to
hear from each witness with firsthand
knowledge a fair trial requires nothing
less let's look at some of the evidence
that we gather notwithstanding this
obstruction first present withheld the
aid without explanation and against the
advice of his own agency's cabinet
officials national security experts
including secretary Pompeo secretary
Esper ambassador bolton and others only
Mick Mulvaney a central figure in this
effort reportedly supported the hold and
he told us why during a press briefing
Mullaney personally acknowledge that the
hold was ordered as part of a quid pro
quo designed to get ukraine to undertake
the investigation president Trump's son
second the reason for the security
assistance hold was undoubtedly on the
president's mind during the telephone
call with president Solinsky on July
25th near the beginning of their
conversation President Solinsky
expressed his gratitude for US military
assistance noting the United States
quote great support in the area of
defense immediately after President
solinsky's reference to defense and
military support President Trump
responded by saying I would like you to
do us a favor though because our country
has been through a lot and Ukraine knows
a lot about it
president Trump then proceeded to openly
press Ukraine to conduct these
investigations third numerous officials
were aware that President Trump was
withholding the White House meeting
until the Ukrainian president announced
the investigations that the president
would ratchet up pressure on Ukraine to
compel its action stunned Ukraine
experts like ambassador Taylor but
followed logically for those engaged in
the president's corrupt scheme forth by
the end of August there was still no
explanation for the hold despite ongoing
efforts from numerous officials to
persuade the president to release the
money and the leverage of the White
House meeting had not succeeded in
coercing Ukraine to announce the
investigations
providing the president and his agents
every reason to use the most aggressive
lever of influence hundreds of millions
from to compel Ukraine to act if they
didn't feel pressure they would have
done it they would have done it but of
course they did imagine if this country
were dependent on a more powerful
country for our defense imagine we were
at war imagine we were waiting for
weapons to defend ourselves something
our framers could have understood
imagine that we found ourselves in those
circumstances and much to our
astonishment we couldn't even get a
meeting with our ally much to our
astonishment they were withholding aid
from us you think we'd feel pressure of
course we would the framers had common
sense and so must we are we to accept
well the president said there was no
quid pro quo I guess that closes the
case in every courtroom in America
jurors and I know you're not just jurors
I read a Clinton trial your jurors and
judges jurors all over America are told
you don't leave your common sense at the
door well we don't have to leave our
common sense at the door here too two
plus two equals four the eight is
withheld you're asking for it we're
asking for it his own aides are asking
for it no one can get an explanation
Ukrainians can't get an explanation all
the Ukrainians get is we want you to do
these investigations they're promised a
White House meeting they want a White
House meeting they need a White House
meeting they're going to be going into
negotiations with Putin they want to
show strength they can't get in the door
they see the Russian Foreign Minister
get in the door of the White House we
see the photos of the president the
russian foreign minister or the
ambassador what a great time they're
having but but no the president our of
Ukraine our ally can't get in the door
they're not stup
they know what's going on here they're
not stupid that conversation I
referenced yesterday when the Ukrainians
threw it right back in our face when
ambassador Volcker said to his Ukrainian
counterpart you shouldn't investigate
the former president we shouldn't have
guests engage in those political
investigations oh the Ukrainian response
was you mean like the one you want us to
do of the Biden's on the Clintons
they're not stupid
by the end of August there was still no
explanation for the hold
despite efforts by numerous people to
seek the release of the funding the
leverage hadn't succeeded in getting the
president to in course Ukraine to
announce the investigations and so the
aid was withheld to witness privily this
scheme testified that the only logical
conclusion to reach about the
president's continued hold on the aid
was that was intended to put more
pressure on Ukraine to announce the
investigations as I said they testified
it was as simple as two plus two equals
four we could do math and more
importantly so can the Ukrainians and
maybe even more importantly than that so
can the Russians multiple seal on the a
of confirmed this logical conclusion on
September 7th ambassador Sandlin spoke
directly to president Trump who by that
point was aware that a whistleblower
complaint was circulating that alleged
the contours of his scheme and that
Congress and the public were beginning
to ask probing questions about the hold
on aid including whether the with
holding of the aid was in exchange for
re-election help during that call
September 7th so July you've got
Muller's testimony you've got the call
itself
you've got the follow-up call the next
day with the president to speak into
sunland wants to make sure they're going
to do the investigations you've got
August while they're trying to hammer
out a statement and the Ukrainians are
still resisting and then you have
September September 7th Ambassador saw
them on the phone with President Trump
at that point he's aware that a
whistleblower has filed a complaint
alleging the contours of this scheme and
Congress and the public are beginning to
ask questions about the hold on aid
including whether this was to get help
in his reelection
and during this call between the Prez
in Ambassador Sundlun without a prompt
president Trump told Sunland there's no
quid pro quo
now why would he do that that's not
something that comes up in normal
conversation right hello mr. president
how are you today no quid pro quo that's
the kind of thing that comes up in a
conversation if you're trying to put
your alibi out there if you've heard
about a whistleblower complaint if
you've seen allegations if you know
Congress is starting to sniff around no
quid pro quo but and I know this is
astonishing so much of the last three
years has been a combination of shock
and yet no surprise and yet even while
the president is saying no quid pro quo
what does he say zalinsky must publicly
announce the two political
investigations and he should want to do
it no quid pro quo accept this quid pro
quo
Soglin immediately relayed the message
to president Solinsky informing him that
without the announcement of the
political investigations they would be
at a stalemate
Saarland made clear that this reference
to a stalemate meant the release of the
security assistance president Solinsky
after hesitating for weeks to join the
president's corrupt scheme finally
relented president Solinsky informed
Sandlin they agreed to do a CNN
interview and Solomon understood that he
would use that occasion to mention these
items to meaning the two investigations
at the heart of the scheme the
candidates elinsky who was swept into
office with a landslide victory on a
promise of fighting corruption would be
forced to undertake just the same kind
of corrupt act
he'd been elected to clean up
upon learning this ambassador Taylor
called Sandlin to register his deep
concern telling him on prom crazy Taylor
later texted Sandlin to reinforce the
point as I said on the phone I think
it's crazy to withhold security
assistance for help with a political
campaign as I said on the phone clearly
they had discussed it as I said on the
phone
Taylor testified about the message and
the events leading up to it Taylor said
that security system was so assistance
was so I'm sorry security system was so
important for Ukraine as well as our own
national interest to withhold that
assistance for no good reason other than
help with the political campaign made no
sense
it was counterproductive to all of what
we had been trying to do it was
illogical it could not be explained it
was crazy
what's more ambassador Taylor also came
to learn that President Trump wanted
szalinski in a public box he testified
mr. Goldman asking the question now you
referenced the television interview and
a desire for President Trump to put
szalinski in a public box which you also
have in quotes was that in your notes
now this is a reference I think to his
written testimony was that reference to
in a public box in his notes memory kept
detailed notes Taylor's answer it was in
my notes and what did you understand to
mean to put szalinski in a public box
and Taylor responds I understood that to
mean that President Trump through
ambassador Sunland was asking for
President Solinsky to publicly commit to
these investigations that it was not
sufficient to do this in private that
this needed to be done this needed to be
a very public state
so we saw earlier the side-by-side
comparison right of what the Ukrainians
wanted to say they wanted to make no
mention of these specific investigations
and now Giuliani insisted no no this
isn't going to be credible unless you
mentioned the specific investigation
this is what it's going to take and now
you see ambassador Sandlin has
acknowledged to ambassador Taylor that
not enough to use even the right
language apparently got to be done in
public we're not going to take any
private commitment it's got to be done
in public as we were later come to
understand this is because President
Trump didn't care about the
investigations being done
he just wanted them announced he wanted
Solinsky in a public box he wanted it
announced publicly a master tailor also
testified that he understood from sahlan
that because President Trump was a
businessman he would expect to get
something in return before signing a
check during our meeting during our call
on September 8th ambassador Solomon
tried to explain to me the president
Trump is a businessman when a
businessman is about to sign a cheque to
someone who owes him something the
businessman asked that person to pay up
before signing the check Oh sir Volker
used the same language several days
later while we were together at the
Yalta European strategy conference I
argued to both that the explanation may
try to did not owe President Trump
anything I this is very telling
bastard tailor Vietnam veteran West
Point graduate Ukrainians didn't owe us
anything
clearly Donald Trump felt the Ukrainians
owed him right this is not about
Ukraine's national security it's not
about our national security
it's not about corruption
no it's about what's in it for me
those Ukrainians owe me before I sign a
check and by the way that's not his
money that's your money
that's the American people's money for
their defense but here we see the master
sunland expect you explaining no
president Trump's a businessman before
he's gonna sign a check he wants to get
something and of course that's something
that he won't he was gonna sign that
check where he's gonna make that payment
for with our tax dollars that thing that
he was going to buy with those tax
dollars was a smear of his opponent and
an effort to lift whatever cloud he felt
was over his presidency because of the
Russian interference on his behalf in
the last election now the president has
offered a assortment of shifting
explanations after the fact for the hold
on aid including that he withheld the
money because of corruption in Ukraine
or concerns about burden sharing with
other European countries but those
arguments are completely without merit
first the president's own administration
had determined by the time of the hold
that Ukraine had undertaken all
necessary anti-corruption and defense
reforms in order to receive the funds
the Defense Department and State
Department officials repeatedly made
this clear as the hold remained and
threatened the ability of the agencies
to spend the money before the end of the
fiscal year
second the evidence revealed that the
president only asked about foreign
contributions to Ukraine in September
nearly two months after the president
implemented the hold and as it became
clear that the public Congress and a
whistleblower were becoming aware of the
president's scheme the after-the-fact
effort to come up with a justification
also belies the truth the European
countries provide far more financial
support to Ukraine than the United
States their support is largely economic
ours also includes a lot of military
support but Europe is a
substantial financial backer of Ukraine
something else remarkable about this I
was struck by yesterday as we going
through the importance of the witness
testimony and looking at some of those
redacted emails in which the
administration sought to hide its
misconduct in those redactions when we
got to see what was beneath them and
there was an indication this is very
close hold this is a need-to-know basis
only remember that we'll show you that
again but one of those emails it only
came to light I believe recently and not
because the administration wanted you
back we see there's a desire not to let
people know about this whole if the
president was fighting corruption if he
wanted Europeans to pay more why would
he hide it from us why he hide it from
Ukrainian so why are we hide from the
rest of the world if this was a desire
to Europe to pay more why wouldn't he
charge Sahlin to go last year for more
why wouldn't he be proud to tell the
Congress the United States I'm holding
up this aid and I'm holding it up
because I'm worried about corruption
why wouldn't he because of course it
wasn't true there's no evidence of that
and what's more the White House admitted
why the president held up the money the
president's own chief of staff explained
precisely why during October 17th and
October 17th press conference let's see
again what he had to say and that was
those were the driving factors that he
also mentioned to me and passed the the
the the corruption related to the DNC
server absolutely no question about that
but that's it that's why we held up the
money now there was a report
the man for an investigation into the
Democrats was part of the reason that he
it was on to withhold funding to Ukraine
we look back to what happened in 2016
certainly was was part of the thing that
he was worried about in corruption with
that nation then that is absolutely
appropriate but Mullaney didn't just
admit that the president withheld the
crucial aid appropriated by Congress to
apply pressure on Ukraine to do the
president's political dirty work he also
said that we should just get over it
let's let's watch describe is a quid pro
quo it is funding will not flow unless
the investigation into the into the
democratic server as well we do we do
that all the time with foreign policy if
you read the news reports and you
believe them what a McKinney say
yesterday when McKinney said yesterday
that he was really upset with the
political influence in foreign policy
that was one of the reasons he was so
upset about this and I have news for
everybody get over it
there's going to be political influence
in foreign policy should the Congress
just get over it sure the American
people just come to expect that our
presidents will corruptly abuse their
office to seek the help of a foreign
power to cheat in our elections should
we just get over it
is that what we've come to I hope and
pray that the answer is no we cannot
allow a president to withhold military
aid from an ally at war for a listed
help in a really election campaign I
hope that we don't have to just get over
that I hope that we just don't have to
get accustomed to that is that what we
want to tell our constituents yeah the
president withheld aid from now.i
yeah it damaged our national security
and yeah he wouldn't meet with a foreign
leader who's important
to us unless you got help in the next
election and yeah it's wrong to try to
get a foreign power to help it's kind of
cheating really we're gonna be honest
about it blatant about it cheating
Americans are supposed to decide
American elections but you know I guess
we just need to get over it I guess
that's just what we should now expect of
a president United States
I guess there's really no remedy for
that anymore the impeachment I mean
maybe that was a good idea 200 years ago
but I guess we just need to get over it
I guess maybe the president really is
above the law because they say you can't
indict the president the president says
you can't even investigate the president
the president is is in court saying you
cannot only not indict the president you
can't even investigate the president
Attorney General's position is you can't
even investigate the president are we
really prepared to say that the only
answer to presidential misconduct is we
just need to get over it
what are we to say with the next
president what we just say with the
president who is from a different party
who refuses the same kind of subpoenas
and the president says to you or as
chief of staff says to you or her chief
of staff says to you just get over it
I'm not doing anything different than
Donald Trump did just get over it
he asked for help in the next election
I'm asking for help in the next election
just get over it we do this kind of
thing all the time people are cynical
enough as it is about about politics
about people's commitment to their good
cynical enough without having us confirm
it for them
I think it's more than crazy that was
ambassador Taylor's work I word I think
it's more than crazy I think it's a
gross abuse of power
and I don't think that impeachment power
is a relic if it is a relic I wonder how
much longer our republic can succeed for
months president Trump and his agents at
pressured Ukraine to announce
investigations and president Solinsky
finally yielded as previously noted he
scheduled a CNN interview and planned to
publicly announce the politically
motivated investigations he informs
online of this plan during a September
7th phone call and the same call Salman
related to president Solinsky that Trump
required that the Ukrainian leader make
the public announcement in order to get
the critical military aid president
Trump's corruption had finally worn down
president Solinsky overcoming his effort
to remain true to his anti-corruption
platform until events intervened before
szalinski could do the interview
president Trump learned that his scheme
had been exposed facing public and
congressional pressure on September 11th
the president finally released the hold
on a to Ukraine just like with the
implementation of the hold he provided
no reason for the release but the reason
is quite simple the president got caught
in late August president Trump learned
about a whistleblower complaint that was
winding its way through the intelligence
agencies on its way to Congress on
September 9th three House committees
announced an investigation into
president Trump's Ukraine misconduct and
that of his proxy Rudy Giuliani later
that day again September 9th
the intelligence community Inspector
General notified the Senate and House
intelligence committees of the existence
of the complaint and the fact that it
was being withheld from Congress
contrary to law
and in an unprecedented fashion facing
significant public pressure on September
11th the president gave up and released
the money to Ukraine
one week later president Solinsky
canceled the CNN interview and rather
than demonstrate contrition or
acknowledged wrongdoing the president
instead has continued his effort even
after the impeachment investigation
began he not only continued to call on
Ukraine to investigate his political
opponent and called on China to do the
same this should concern all of us
it's a confirmation on only the scheme
to pressure Ukraine to help his
political campaign but a clear sign that
the President believes that these
corrupt acts are acceptable a president
this unapologetic this lawless this
unbound to the Constitution and the oath
of office must be removed from that
office lest he continued to use the vast
presidential powers at his disposal to
seek advantage in the next election
president Trump's abuse of powers of his
office undermine the integrity of our
free and fair elections and compromised
America's national security if we don't
stand up to this peril today we will
write the history of our decline with
our own hand the president Trump is not
held to account we send the message to
future presidents future congresses and
generations of Americans that the
personal interests of the president can
fairly take precedent over those of the
nation the domestic effects of this
dissent from democracy will be a
weakened trust in the integrity of our
elections and the rule of law and a
steady decline of the spread of
democratic values throughout the world
for how can any country trust the United
States as a model of governing
if it is one that sanctions precisely
the political corruption an invitation
to foreign meddling that we have long
sought to help eradicate in burgeoning
democracies around the world to protect
against foreign intellect interference
in our elections we have guardrails
built into our democratic system we have
campaign finance laws to ensure that
political assistance can come only from
domestic actors and we take seriously
the need to shore up the integrity of
our voting systems so that a foreign
government or actor cannot change vote
tallies the promise of one person one
vote is only effective if each vote is
cast free of foreign interference
Americans decide American elections at
least they should
now what if electoral corruption is even
more insidious what happens when the
invitation comes from within
our framers understood that threat to
George Mason noted at the Constitutional
Convention that impeachment was a
necessary tool because the man who has
practiced corruption and by that means
procured his appointment in the first
instance could seek to repeat his guilt
in June of last year President Trump was
clear that if a foreign government
offered dirt on his political opponent
he would take it a statement deeply at
odds with the guidance provided at the
time by his own FBI director the formal
Federal Elections Commission earned
chair and our Constitution written some
233 years ago in no uncertain terms in
admonishes that any person holding
office of profit or trust it admonishes
against them accepting of any present
from a foreign state but President Trump
did more than take the foreign help in
2019 as he had done in 2016 not only
asked for it in the July 25th call but
when he didn't get the help from the
Ukrainian president in
form of the announce till in
investigations he withheld hundreds of
millions of dollars in taxpayer-funded
military aid and a coveted White House
meeting to increase the pressure on
Ukraine to comply and later he
demonstrated no remorse and continued to
encourage Ukraine to conduct the
political investigations he wanted even
asking other countries to do so the
consequences of these actions alone have
shaken our democratic system what
message will we send if we choose not to
hold this president accountable for his
abuse of power till it's illicit
reelection interest interference in our
upcoming election in this conduct
undertaken by this president may lead
future presidents to believe that they
too can use a substantial power
conferred on them by the Constitution in
order to undermine it
nothing could weaken the integrity of
your elections more and no campaign
finance law or statement by a future FBI
director could stand up to the precedent
of electoral misconduct set by the
President of the United States if we do
not say clearly that this behavior is
unacceptable and more than unacceptable
impeachable we also undermine our global
standing as a country long viewed as a
model for democratic ideals worth
emulating we have for generations been
the shining city upon a hill that
President Reagan described America is
not just a country but also an idea but
what Worth is that idea if when tried we
do not affirm the values that underpin
it what will those nascent democracies
around the world conclude that democracy
is not only difficult but maybe that
it's too difficult maybe that it's
impossible and who will come to fill the
void that we leave when the light from
that shining city upon a hill is
extinguished the autocrats with whom
compete who value not freedom and fair
elections but the unending rule of a
repressive executive autocrats that
value not freedom of the press an open
debate but disinformation propaganda and
state sanctioned lies Vladimir Putin
would like nothing better the russians
have little democracy left thanks to
vladimir putin
it's an autocracy it's a thug ah cracy
the russians storyline the russian
narrative the russian propaganda the
russian view they would like people
around the world to believe is that
every country is just the same just the
same corrupt system there's no
difference it's not a competition
between autocracy and democracy no it's
just between autocrats and hypocrites
they make no bones about their loss of
democracy they just want the rest of the
world to believe you can't find it
anywhere why take to the streets in
Moscow to demand something better if
there's nothing better anywhere else
that's the Russian story between that's
the Russian story that's who prospers by
the defeat of democracy that's who wins
by the defeat of our democratic ideals
it's not other democracies
it's the autocrats we're on the rise all
over the world I think all of us in this
room have grown up in a generation where
each successive generation lived with
more freedom than the one that came
before we each had more freedom of
speech and Association freedom to
practice our faith this was true at home
it was true all over the world and I
think we came to believe this was some
in beautiful law of nature
only to find it isn't only to come to
the terrible realization that this year
fewer people live in freedom that lasts
and there's no guarantee that next year
people will live and more freedom that
today and the prospect for our children
is even more in doubt turns out there's
nothing immutable about this every
generation has to fight for it we're
fighting for it right now there's no
guarantee that this democracy that has
served us so well will continue to
prosper we will struggle to protect this
idea and even as we do we will struggle
to protect our security and more
tangible ways support for an independent
and democratic Ukraine which is the
littoral bulwark against Russian
expansionism in Europe is essential to
our security Russia showed that would
have aided Ukraine in 2014 and sought to
redraw the map of Europe was our
commitment to Ukraine's independence and
sovereignty just an empty promise or are
we prepared to support its efforts to
keep Russia contained so that they and
we may all eventually enjoy a long peace
Russia is not a threat I don't need to
tell you to Eastern Europe alone Ukraine
has become the de-facto proving ground
for just the types of hybrid warfare
that the 21st century will become
defined by cyberattacks disinformation
campaigns efforts to undermine the
legitimacy of state institutions whether
that is voting systems or financial
markets the Kremlin showed boldly in
2016 that with the malign skills at
honed in Ukraine they would not stay in
Ukraine instead Russia employed them
here
to attack our institutions and they will
do so again indeed they've never stopped
will we allow the primary country now
fighting Russia to be weakened placing
our troops in Europe at greater risk and
opening the door to greater interference
in our affairs at home if we allow the
president United States to pursue his
political and personal interests rather
than the national interest we send a
message to our European allies that our
commitment to a Europe free and the
whole is for sale to the highest bidder
it troops in Europe on a shared
understanding of what that Alliance
stands for one built on the rule of law
on free and fair elections on a shared
struggle against aggression from
autocratic regimes we are countries
built on a commitment to our people not
unyielding loyalty to a president who
would be king a president has a right to
hold a call with a foreign leader yes
and he has the right to decide the time
and location of a meeting with that
leader yes and he has a right to
withhold funding to that leader should
the law be followed and the purpose be
just but he does not under our laws and
under our Constitution have a right to
use the powers of his office to
corruptly solicit foreign aid prohibited
foreign aid in his reelection he does
not he does not have the right to
withhold official presidential acts to
secure that assistance and he certainly
does not have the right to undermine our
elections and place our security at risk
for his own personal benefit no
president Republican or Democrat can be
permitted to do that now let me turn to
the second article of impeachment which
charges the president with misusing the
powers of his office to obstruct and
interfere with the impeachment inquiry
the evidential here during the house
presentation is equally undeniable and
damning President Trump
issued a blanket order directing the
entire executive branch not to cooperate
with the impeachment inquiry and to
withhold all
documents and testimony his order was
categorical it was indiscriminate and
historically unprecedented no president
before President Trump has ever ordered
the complete defiance of an impeachment
inquiry or sought to obstruct and impede
so comprehensively the ability of the
House of Representatives to investigate
high crimes and misdemeanors the
president was able to block agencies
across the executive branch from
producing any records or documents to
the House investigative committees
despite duly authorized subpoenas the
White House continues to refuse to
produce a single document or record in
response to a house subpoena that
remains in full force and effect the
Department of State and Office of
Management and Budget the Department of
Energy the Department of Defense
continued to refuse to provide a single
document or record in response to how
subpoenas that remain in full force and
effect it is worth underscoring this
point the House has yet to receive a
single document from the executive
branch agencies pursuant to its
subpoenas not a single piece of paper
email or other record has been turned
over not one and while I paused to get a
drink of water let me let you know for
your timing I have about ten minutes
left in my presentation so the end is in
sight
president Trump has also successfully
blocked witnesses nine of them under
subpoena from testifying witnesses with
first-hand knowledge of the president's
actions including his closest aides some
of whom were directly involved in
executing the president's improper
orders
these would Lanie and Robert Blair
Russell Vaught the acting head of the
Office of Management and Budget Michael
Duffy a senior official and the
president's chief legal advisor on the
National Security Council John Eisenberg
among others the managers will present
in detail what these officials knew
about their role in executing different
parts of the president's scheme there's
no dispute nor could there be that
president trumps or substantially
obstructed the house impeachment inquiry
that obstruction continues unabated
today even as we stand here at the start
of the president's trial and the
president has been able to do so only
because of the uniquely powerful
position that he holds as our commander
in chief no other American could seek to
obstruct an investigation into his own
wrongdoing this way no other American
could use the vast powers and levers of
his government to conduct a corrupt
scheme to benefit themselves and then
use those same powers to suppress
evidence and bar any cooperation with
the authorities investigating them not a
police chief not a mayor not a governor
not any elected official in the country
and certainly not any non elected
official in the country all those folks
watching us from around the country you
know what would happen to them if they
defied a lawful subpoena they got a
subpoena commanding them to appear you
know what would happen to them because
they're not above the law they'd be
arrested they'd be detained they'd be
incarcerated they would be forced to
comply
they're not above the law and neither a
we and neither is the president and yet
despite the fact that he is not above
the law the president's extensive and
persistent efforts the president the
house heard from courageous witnesses
who did obey lawful subpoenas and we
gathered overwhelming evidence the house
built a formidable case that forms the
basis of these articles the second
article for obstruction of Congress is
not simply about President Trump's
decision to obstruct a congressional
investigation or even an impeachment
inquiry it should not be misunderstood
as routine dispute between two branches
of government nor should it be reduced
to the notion that the president was
simply protecting himself or fighting
back against a partisan or overzealous
Congress the charges in the second
article are much more serious and urgent
than that first the president's attempt
to obstruct the inquiry so categorically
and comprehensively is part and parcel
of the president's furious effort to
conceal suppress and cover up his own
misconduct from the very first moment
his actions were at the risk of coming
to light President Trump sought to hide
and cover up key evidence even as his
scheme to pressure Ukraine was still
under way as the house presentation will
make clear the president's cover-up
started even before the house began to
investigate the president's Ukraine
related activity the president learned
early on of the existence of a lawful
whistleblower complaint from within the
intelligence community that would ring
the first alarm he deployed the White
House and Justice Department to
intervene in an unprecedented fashion to
conceal and then withhold from Congress
for the first time ever a credible and
urgent whistleblower complaint even
though the law requires that it be
provided to the congressional
intelligence committees once the
impeachment inquiry was underway in late
September the president used the immense
and unique power
at his disposal to direct and maintain
at every turn the categorical defiance
of congressional scrutiny even as the
intact the inquiry itself and its
witnesses the president offered multiple
and shifting justifications obstructing
for obstructing the house's inquiry each
of them deficient while his actions and
statements powerfully reflect his own
consciousness of guilt second the
ramifications of the president's
obstruction go beyond the sinister
motives of simply covering up his
actions his obstruction strikes at the
heart of our Constitution it threatens
the last line of defense
our founders purposely enshrine in our
system to protect our democracy if
presidents can obstruct an impeachment
inquiry undertaken by the house and
evade accountability in the Senate for
doing so they usurp an essential power
granted exclusively to the Congress and
for a reason presidents could seize for
themselves the power to neutralize and
nullify the impeachment clause in order
to shield themselves from any
accountability and if Congress is unable
to investigate and a peach a present for
abuse of their office our democracy's
essential check on a rogue president
fail it would no longer protect the
American people from a corrupt president
who presents an ongoing threat this is
the outcome every American should be
concerned about and one that the
founders warned us about through the
impeachment Clause the framers of the
Constitution empowered Congress to
thoroughly investigate presidential
malfeasance and to respond if necessary
by removing the president from office
this entire framework depends upon
Congress's ability to discover and then
to thoroughly and effectively
investigate presidential misconduct
without the ability of Congress to do
that the impeachment power is a nullity
if you can't investigate it you can't
enforce it you can't apply it what we
confront here in the SEC
article of impeachment is therefore an
impeachable offense aimed at destroying
the impeachment power itself when a
president abuses the power of his office
to so completely defy house
investigators and does so without lawful
cause or excuse he attacks the
Constitution itself he confirms that he
sees himself as above the law
his actions destabilized the separation
of powers that defines our democracy and
preserves our freedom and establish an
exceedingly dangerous precedent and he
proves that he is willing to destroy a
vital safeguard against tyranny a
safeguard meant to protect the American
people
just to advance his own personal
interest in covering up evidence the
house presentation of the second article
will therefore focus on three core areas
that confirm the president's obstruction
and require his removal from office
first the singular importance and role
of the impeachment clause for our
democracy and why an effort by a
president to obstruct an impeachment
inquiry is in and of itself an
impeachable offense second why the
president's extensive effort to cover up
evidence of his misconduct is
unprecedented in American history and
without lawful cause or justification
and finally why the president's
obstruction poses a direct threat to our
system of self-governance with
consequences for all Americans today and
in the future and for both chambers of
Congress over the coming days you will
hear from the house managers details of
this scheme and the effort to hide it
from Congress the articles of
impeachment that the house presented go
to the heart of those efforts and let me
share a few key tape
takeaways the House of Representatives
has found that using the powers of his
eyes office President Trump solicited
the interference of a foreign
in Ukraine in the 2020 US presidential
election he did so through a scheme or
course of conduct that included
soliciting the government of Ukraine to
publicly announce investigations that
would benefit his reelection harm the
election prospects of a political
opponent and influenced the 2020 u.s.
presidential election improperly into
his advantage president Trump also
sought to pressure the government
Ukraine to take these steps by
conditioning official United States
governed acts of significant value to
Ukraine on Ukraine's public announcement
of these investigations and he engaged
in this scheme or course of conduct for
corrupt purposes in pursuit of his
personal political benefit in doing so
President Trump used the powers of the
presidency in a manner that compromised
the national security of the United
States and undermined the integrity of
the u.s. democratic process he thus
ignored and injured the interests of the
nation as part of the houses impeachment
inquiry the committee's undertaking that
investigation serve subpoenas seeking
documents in testimony deemed vital to
the inquiry from various executive
branch agencies and offices current and
former officials in response and without
lawful cause or excuse president Trump
directed executive branch agencies
offices and officials not to comply with
those subpoenas president Trump thus
interposed the powers of the presidency
against the lawful subpoenas of the
House of Representatives and assumed to
himself functions and judgments
necessary to the exercise of the sole
power of impeachment vested by the
Constitution in the House of
Representatives
as George Washington and his troops
retreated across the Delaware River in
early 17 December 1776 they were read
the words of Thomas Paine published that
month in his pamphlet American crisis
these are the times that try men's souls
the summer soldier and the sunshine
patriot will in this crisis shrink from
the service of their country but he that
stands by it now deserves the love and
thanks of man and woman 17 days later
George Washington crossed the Delaware
leading to a decisive victory for those
who had come to shape our promising
young country as much as our founders
feared and unchecked chief executive
able to pursue his own will over the
will of the people they also feared the
poison of excessive factionalism that
could divert us from a difficult service
to our country as George Washington
warned in his farewell address the
common and continual mischiefs of the
spirit of party are sufficient to make
it the interest and duty of a wise
people do discourage and restrain it now
our political parties and affiliations
are central to our democracy insuring
that good and bad political philosophies
alike are considered in the marketplace
of ideas here the American people can
choose between the policies of what we
do
seasons about their political leaders up
to and including the President of the
United States based on the degree to
which that person represents their
interests and values that is not
factionalism that is the foundation of
our democracy but when a leader takes
the reins reins of the highest office in
our land and uses that awesome power to
solicit the help of a foreign country to
gain an unfair advantage in our free and
fair elections
we all Democrats and Republicans alike
must ask ourselves whether our loyalty
is to our party or whether it is to our
Constitution if we say that we will
align ourselves with that leader
allowing our sense of duty to be usurped
by an absolute executive that is not
democracy it is not even factionalism it
is a step on the road towards tyranny
the damage that this president has done
to our relationship with a key strategic
partner will be remedied over time and
Ukraine continues to enjoy strong
bipartisan support in Congress but if we
fail to act the damage to our democratic
elections to our national security to
our system of checks and balances will
be long lasting and potentially
irreversible as you will hear in the
coming days
president Trump has acted in a manner
grossly incompatible with self
governance his conduct has violated his
oath of office and his constitutional
duty to faithfully execute the law he
has shown no willingness to be
constrained by the rule of law and has
demonstrated that he will continue to
abuse his power and obstruct
investigations into himself causing
further damage to the pillars of our
democracy if he is not held accountable
he cannot be charged with a crime so
says the Department of Justice there is
no remedy for such a threat but removal
from office of the President of the
United States
if impeachment and removal cannot hold
him accountable then he truly is above
the law we are nearly two and a half
centuries into this beautiful experiment
of American democracy but our future is
not assured as Benjamin Franklin
departed the Constitutional Convention
he was asked what have we got a republic
or a monarchy he responded simply a
republic if you can keep it
a fair trial impartial consideration of
all of the evidence against the
president is how we keep our Republic
that concludes our introduction the
Majority Leader's office colleagues I
suggest we have a recess until 10
minutes to 4:00 at which moment we'll
reconvene something to call the chair
without objection so ordered
Jaxson
[Music]